[Music]
hey guys pete here today i'm going to
give you my spoiler-free impressions of
the expanse season 6. i don't usually do
videos like this and i don't normally
watch too far ahead when i have
screeners for a show but i started this
and even with taking notes and reading
the ninth book leviathan falls i still
ended up getting through it in a few
days and they did send out all six
episodes so here we are and there's a
lot of good to talk about here and i can
do that in a pretty spoiler-free way i'm
definitely not going to spoil any major
plot points so unless you just don't
want to know anything you should be able
to watch this video and with that out of
the way let's get into it
i suppose the main question you have if
you're here is is it a good ending and i
think the answer to that is yes given
the situation that this is the last
season that amazon prime video is making
i think it does a solid job of wrapping
up the story where it is and it leaves
things open for a future adaptation
there's still three more books to go my
quick spoiler-free review of leviathan
falls is they did stick the landing and
i hope that we'll one day be able to see
it but there's a lot to like in this
sixth season of the show there are some
really memorable character moments i
won't get into any specifics but holden
naomi and amos all had at least one
scene that hit harder than it had a
right to some of the changes they made
to the story helped to set some of these
up which means they're not necessarily
things that people who read the books
are waiting for which is a nice bonus
drummer has a scene that probably takes
the cake in this category for me but
whoever your favorite character is they
probably have a spotlight moment it does
feel like a final season in that regard
there are some really good callbacks and
some characters from prior seasons
popped back up there was at least one
that was kind of obscure and put a smile
on my face because i wasn't expecting it
that happens in the premiere and i think
you'll know the character from season 1
i'm talking about when you see it not to
create unrealistic expectations here
though there are definitely some that
are missing and are missed as far as how
the book played out there are a handful
of point of view characters from the
book that aren't even mentioned or
hinted at on the show another plus is
that there is a lot of high quality
space porn and not just battles but
there are those too but there's just a
lot of stuff that really looks authentic
here and they spend a lot of time in the
rasanante and it feels like we see more
of that than we ever did in the past
there's one scene in the premiere where
amos goes outside for some maintenance
and it's just leagues ahead of anything
they did in those first few seasons it's
not flashy or impressive other than it
just looks like wes chatham is actually
in a spacesuit in space walking on the
outside of a spaceship to do a job and
it's the way that they track him and how
it's set up perfectly it just allows
them to flex their muscles and show how
good they've gotten all of this over the
years there's another thing later in the
season where with a lesser show you
might think oh now you're just showing
off but the whole thing makes sense and
it's a cool sequence that feels like it
was spawned from writers who know what
their vfx crew is capable of the visual
effects also have pretty consistently
improved season after season and there
are some real set pieces here to look
forward to as i said the crew are in the
rossi for most of the season and there
are some battles going on which they
always do pretty well but i don't think
it's as wall to wall as some fans might
have been hoping i think realistically
it's on par with about how much we saw
in season five except there is one
really big and crazy season defining
sequence which didn't really disappoint
book readers will likely know what i'm
referring to here and it doesn't play
out exactly the same but they managed to
add a little more intensity with some of
the changes they made and overall most
of the changes in the season worked that
way but they also did cut out a lot
which makes me wonder how easy it will
be to follow for non-book readers and
that brings up some of the criticisms i
have it is super short there's just no
getting around it it's mostly paced well
as in it's in good hands as far as
streamlining things without dropping
important character stuff but it's still
less than 5 hours total and it goes by
fast with 45 minute episodes plus i'd
love that they added strange dogs and i
think it works well alongside with
what's happening in seoul but that takes
up a handful of minutes in a cold open
in every single episode another thing is
that you can tell this season is
different because of kovid it's subtle
but you can tell that they were
restricted in some ways i can't say for
sure but it seems possible that this has
something to do with which characters
they brought back and which ones they
didn't there are at least a few
characters who i expected to be involved
that are barely mentioned if at all it
just feels like they couldn't get them
back under these conditions and there
are some brand new characters which is
where i think the shortness really makes
a difference the casting and the
performances are good but if you're not
really paying attention to the dialogue
you might find yourself later thinking
like why is this person here there's
just not enough time to develop them and
there are other decisions they made that
seem to be a result of some combination
of these two things so there are some
issues i should mention that the
showrunner said at the new york city
comic con that there would be additional
shorts in the x-ray extras between each
episode i haven't seen those and they
could fill in some of the details that
feel light in these episodes apparently
there's going to be many episodes
between the episodes there was one
sequence that i was really looking
forward to seeing from the books that i
didn't think translated that well to the
show it was still good but i didn't
think it had the same tension and i'm
not sure it would come off as impressive
if you hadn't read the books but they
did add some interesting stuff i was
caught by surprise at a couple of points
and they definitely played around with
the idea that they could kill someone
off i won't confirm if they did or not
but there was at least one time when i
was yelling at the screen because i was
convinced it was a setup to end the
character overall i think they made it
work there's a nice balance between the
big stuff that's going on in space and
the intimate moments that happen on the
ship in between the characters and in
some ways it doesn't feel like the
ending we want as far as we know there's
more there but they made the end that we
get count and i think that's a good
place to leave things i'm gonna be
breaking down every episode as they come
out so i really don't need to say much
more here it's fast but it's not game of
thrones season eight i can guarantee
that to be fair though it does have a
much shorter run time than that i've
seen some things that i always wanted to
see on screen and i'm pretty happy about
it so let me know what you're hoping to
see and how you think things are gonna
play out please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already make sure
you check out my series recap for
everything you need to remember for
season six and thanks for watching i'll
talk to you soon